we're gonna see more of that Shaq attack
it just makes you smile welcome to CBS
this morning from our house to yours out
of an abundance of caution we're coming
to you once again this morning from our
respective homes you've heard us talk
about social distancing well we are
certainly doing that as we hope you are
too but the most important thing as you
know is that we continue bringing you
the news which we will do throughout
this crisis and that of course is where
we begin Anthony on this April Fool's
Day I wish this was one big bad joke but
unfortunately it's not it's reality and
it's not good yeah and it's getting more
serious Gail we start here this morning
the White House is warning Americans
about a grim reality still to come in a
blunt press conference president Trump's
coronavirus task force at says we should
be prepared for another a hundred
thousand to two hundred and forty
thousand Americans to lose their lives
before the pandemic is over that is up
60 times that is up to 60 times the
current death toll more than 4,000 lives
have been lost in the first month of the
crisis the vast majority just in the
past week around 900 people died
yesterday setting another single day
record weezer jiang is at the White
House we sure the president has mostly
touted the administration's success in
battling with the coronavirus but
yesterday's briefing was markedly
different
good morning Anthony president Trump's
previous attempts to downplay this virus
continue to haunt him though he says he
was just trying to be positive now he is
being blunt it's a matter of life and
death
it's frankly it's a matter of life and
death President Trump warned Americans
the worst is yet to come
this could be a hell of a bad two weeks
the number of cases has not even peaked
and top health officials told people to
prepare for the reality that 100 to 240
thousand Americans could die and that's
with mitigating efforts this is the
thing that we need to anticipate but
that doesn't mean that that's what we're
gonna accept doctors Anthony Fauci and
deborah birx pleaded with the public to
stay at home avoid travel and
cap gatherings at 10:00 people this is
tough people are suffering people are
dying it's inconvenient from a societal
standpoint from an economic standpoint
to go through this but this is gonna be
the answer to our problems there's no
magic bullet there's no magic vaccine or
therapy
it's just behaviors just last week
President Trump said he hoped Americans
would pack into church on Easter and for
weeks he told them the virus was not as
bad as the flu the flu in our country
kills from 25,000 people to 69 thousand
people a year that was shocking to me
and so far if you look at what we have
with the 15 people and they're
recovering one is one is pretty sick but
hopefully we'll recover
but the others are in great shape but
now mr. Trump is sending a very
different message a lot of people have
said a lot of people have thought about
it write it out don't do anything just
write it up and think of it as the flu
but it's not the food it's vicious New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo says
governors are still betting against each
other for medical supplies like
ventilators two weeks ago President
Trump said states should try to get them
on their own but yesterday he said the
government has 10,000 ventilators ready
to go but they are waiting to ship
because the surge is coming and they
want to make sure to send the machines
to the right places when it does Gail we
should thank you